ces problèmes découlent au premier lieu
des défaillances de leur modèle
économiques et de leur dispositif de
gestion des risques notamment en matière
de risque de concentration de taux et de
liquidité à cet égard le défaut de
silicone va les banques représente un
cas d'école la banque était en effet
excessivement concentrée à trois égards
sur le secteur technologique en termes
de clientèle sur un nombre limité de
grands déposants corporate en termes de
ressources de financement et sur une
classe particulière d'actifs liquide en
fait pour un montant qui était supérieur
à la moitié totale des dépôts du total
des dépôts à savoir des bons du Trésor
américain
comptabilisés au coût amorti ce qui a
masqué les pertes la tente associées
la rapide remontait des taux ou
traatlantiques a conduit les clients de
la banque SVB à retirer leurs dépôts
soit pour les placer ailleurs chez les
mieux offrants soit pour financer leur
activité les levées de fonds devenant
plus difficile sur ce secteur alors même
que dans le même temps la valeur de
marché des actifs liquides que
l'établissement pouvait mobiliser pour
rembourser ses dépôts chuter d'où la
matérialisation des pertes jusqu'ici
l'attentes et le défaut de la banque
quant à crédit Suisse s'il a panique du
mois de mars et une communication
particulièrement maladroite de son
principal actionnaire lui ont porté le
coût final en 2023 ce sont bien les
défaillances de son modèle d'affaires et
sa gestion des risques qui avait sapé
depuis des mois la confiance de sa
clientèle et occasionnée des sorties
massives de fonds
si on regarde simplement le quatrième
trimestre 2023 plus de 110 milliards de
francs suisses
à la différence de ces établissements si
on se penche sur les établissements de
crédit français il bénéficie d'un modèle
d'activité diversifiée et on
considérablement renforcé leur structure
financière depuis la crise de 2008 ils
ont d'ailleurs traversé avec succès les
deux périodes de stress précédentes qui
n'étaient pas négligeable la crise covid
bien sûr et les conséquences du conflit
russeau ukrainien
démontrant la résilience de leur modèle
d'affaires et leurs capacité à faire
face à des conditions de marché parfois
très instable
leur cour boursiers n'ont ainsi été que
on va dire modérément affecté par les
turbulences récentes